ministerpräsident bodo ramelow daddelt
vor sich hin während die kanzlerin und
alle anderen länderchefs darüber
streiten wie deutschland durch die
größte krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
kommen soll
candy crash mitten in den wichtigen
beratungen über die richtigen corona
maßnahmen verraten hat dass der linke
politiker ramelow am wochenende selbst
bei einer diskussion auf der neuen live
talk app clubhouse das spielen sei für
ihn eine entspannungsmethode da drin
während gerade über den lockdown beraten
wird der vier millionen deutsche zur
existenzfrage geworden ist wenn ich
sowas lese was der ramelow da gemacht
hat ich als gastronom der schon seit
november gucken muss wir irgendwie zu
rande kommt durch straßenverkauf oder
irgendwelche flyer die man macht man
investiert geld und so weiter und er
stellt sich ihnen beziehungsweise setzt
sich hin und spielt bei jedem einer
wichtigen konferenz auf sein handy rum
darin stocksauer sowas darf es nicht
geben und so ein mann der gleich
abgesetzt also der sollte zurücktreten
wenn ich mich so verhalten wird in
meinem job
da würde ich wahrscheinlich rausfliegen
ich finde es eine absolute frechheit und
ein schlag ins gesicht
zum einheits rettungsdienstler und zum
anderen auch als privatmensch der sich
gedanken darüber macht ob seine kinder
gesund leider nicht unser land kämpft
ums nackte überleben die menschen
kämpfen in den altenheimen ums nackte
überleben politiker die sich hier in den
vordergrund spielen und meinen die
ultimative lösung zu haben spielen candy
crash sager das ist eines politikers und
ministerpräsidenten unwürdig candy crash
dafür brennt bodo ramelow schon länger
2009 10 veröffentlicht die linke
thüringen dieses video schnelligkeit hat
dann seit 2011 bei candy crash ich bin
dabei 4000
398 und nun den er nehmen besser als
youtube könne er politik für alle
menschen in thüringen plakatierte clip
nach den spielszenen
doch fakt ist thüringen macht in der
korona krise bisher keine gute figur
hildburghausen wurde zum absoluten
corona hotspot und geriet in die
schlagzeilen mit besonders
rücksichtslosen demonstranten rahmenlos
bundesland gehört zu den krisen
bundesländern hat mit 204 infektionen
pro 100.000 einwohner derzeit den
höchsten wert und ist somit schlusslicht
die zahl der toten lag in thüringen im
dezember 2020 rund 40 prozent höher als
im durchschnitt der vergangenen vier
jahre
bei den über 80 jährigen lag die zahl
der sterbefälle sogar 60 prozent höher
auf die bevölkerung gerechnet trifft es
thüringen mit 81,2 corona toten pro
100.000 einwohner am zweit schlimmsten
davor liegt nur sachsen und auch beim
impfen in drammen los bundesland im rest
der republik hinterher
thüringen liegt nur auf platz zehn von
16 bundesländern dennoch lässiges darin
während der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
für cdu-chef und nrw-ministerpräsident
armin laschet und denkbar was herr
ramelow da spielt werden mp cars weiß
ich nicht ich spiele keine
computerspiele während
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz weil es in
der tat um sehr sehr wichtige fragen
geht gamer ramelow dagegen erzählt bei
clubhouse munter erschaffe bis zu zehn
level während der stundenlangen
beratungen mit der kanzlerin inzwischen
hat er sich bei twitter zu seiner
clubhouse plauderei öffentlich geäußert
und sich entschuldigt allerdings nicht
fürs daddeln sondern nur für einen
anderen ausrutscher ramelow nannte die
kanzlerin in dem gespräch merklichen